l a tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovo video io sono pari j
oggi siamo finalmente su una delle sfide
che mi state chiedendo ormai da un mese
una cosa impressionante che è la sfida
to the chabib anni allora raga prima di
iniziarla volevo ringraziarvi per questo
traguardo incredibile 30 mila iscritti
non ci posso credere non posso ancora
credere di essere arrivato un traguardo
del genere c'è veramente incredibile
ragazzi vi ringrazia e tra l'altro
mentre uscito questo video non siamo
neanche più a 30mila a 332 mila una roba
del genere va me raga
ormai sto facendo un video speciale ogni
sabato tra l'altro ragazzo adesso deve
uscire il centesimo video che sarà uno
speciale tra pochi da 35mila iscritti
che uno speciale ormai ogni sabato c'è
un [ __ ] video speciale non ce la
faccio più comunque era già prima di
iniziare volevo soltanto dirvi come si
svolgerà questa sfida
anzi queste sfide perché non sarà una ma
due
innanzitutto vi spiego in che cosa
consiste la sfida a dude e chabib anni
allora abbiamo bisogno soltanto di una
cosa ovvero questi
questa roba qui sono marshmallow la
sfida to the chap i panni consiste nel
mettersi in bocca uno alla volta di
questi e ogni volta che lo si inserisce
bisogna dire chabib anni la volta in cui
non si riesce più a dire cha mib anni si
perde prima di montare onde evitare
disputare marshmellow sul monitor e
tutto il resto mi sono anche munito di
cestino
nel caso si verificasse un eruzione
comunque questa è la sfida normale dopo
aver fatto la sfida dei giochi balli
normale parola stessa identica cosa
su happy ovvero ogni volta che morirò
dovrà mettere un mouse belloni bocca e
dire chabib anni quindi ragazzetto
questo direi che possiamo iniziare con
la sfida dude e chabib anni allora
questo è il pacchetto di marshmallow si
accettano scommesse su quanti riesco a
mettermi prima di vomitare
allora ci siamo perfetto il pacchetto da
aperto di a me fanno pure schifo snelle
vabbè raga sono pronto si accettano
scommesse scrivete qui sotto nei
commenti subito quanto pensate che io
riesca a fare vediamo se ci azzecca the
ok sono pronto vai
ok chabib anni è prima andato
ok mica è già difficile che cazzo ok
già vip anni ok siamo due che ha già a
vibo anni no
3 porca [ __ ] quanto calcio no questo
no
kobe boss
[Risate]
troppi bonnie
ciò che i panni
gobbi bonn
dove
all
sì
[Musica]
all
no
che schifo questo caso ho fatto sono
arrivato tipo 78 mio dio la ragazza raga
è il possibile
l'effetto ragazzi amo sua happy socks
mio pacchetto di marshmallow pronto per
essere un uomo divorato proviamoci
allora andiamo solo rainbow lavorando
sono pronto tra virgolette proviamoci
byoc non mi delude brutto stronzo web un
tour embolo al pullman perfetto vai vai
mario che cazzo siamo partiti malissimo
maledizione va bene ok cup i panni ok
il primo è un possibile fare un cazzo di
commento di cos'è che ci prova lo stesso
ragazzo d'oro
no oddio [ __ ]
chabib anni pensiamo 2 con questo
livello di merda che è impossibile
parlare ed i veli di centrare il buco
giusto non mi far incazzare
ok no che culo ho preso che cazzo ci fai
york ma sta ancora bene a no no nuke del
cazzo ma dai
[ __ ] liu questo nell'afa di brutto
stronzo già vip anni ciao 3 [ __ ]
ma che ci sono [ __ ] nonno ciak anche
no no no echi di merda tardi che ma che
ca anche amici mi uccide ma dai ma fa
ancora non c'è raga non ce la farò mai
cioppi bonnie sono qua io mi ha portato
la mia bocca
che cazzo sto facendo non mi deluderà di
call of swing dai cazzo cazzo già
nell'edizione a [ __ ] come cazzo posso
permettermi questo no questo momento fa
un culo ma con questo
non so quanto costi siano non posso non
ci devo riprovare a [ __ ] a chi non vi
deluderò steve non ricco forse non a
caso schepp si appuntava steso tappeti
mettono di mezzo ma niente rothlin groff
ancora
capiva anni che faccio mai
all
il gol
si no
all
[Musica]
si no
google non lo farò mai più
è orribile cioè io entro nei livelli a
caso leggo per farli j
e lì mi mangio 3 marshmallow ma dai è
stato cromatico cazzo vabbè basta non ne
voglio più sentir parlare basta e stata
una cosa bruttissima che quei tre natola
raga ma guarda te che cazzo di
marshmallow cioè io mi mangiavo quelli
normali cioè questi aspettate che ne
trovo uno tipo questi che sono normali
sono marshmallow ma questi guardate che
cazzo di differenza questo vale 2
quindi questi manera che riguardava
bisogna sommitale
a guardarli cazzo io però dico di
stanotte mission di sognare i
marshmallow che mi vengono a bussare
alla porta e mi dicono mangiami mangiami
altro che chiede mario cazzo vabbè raga
io direi di chiudere qui l'episodio è
stata una cosa assurda
voglio ringraziarvi un'altra volta per
il traguardo dei 30 mila iscritti
raggiunto che poi non sono 30 mila ma
sono 32.000 e qualcosa ragazzi un
traguardo assurdo vi ringrazio veramente
di cuore se video vi è piaciuto lasciare
un commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come in ogni video trovate
nella descrizione
se non siet
vorresti di scrivere noi ci vediamo al
prossimo video belle ragazze
[Musica]